something about that is standards it's
pretty easy to drop your standards right
especially in our world where you can
see such a quick return you can talk to
one person introduce them to another
person and before you know it you're
sending out an invoice and it doesn't
necessarily need to be a great deal we
think that short term we've created an
experience that is partnership rather
than execution and it starts at the very
beginning with each partner that we on
board we then measure in a 10-point
system what we're going to help them
with in those conversations sometimes we
see some businesses not prepared to
commit they're not prepared to partner
and sometimes you think would be really
easy to fill that job and then you take
a step back and you think but what's the
candidate experience going to be like
you're not going to be able to manage
and then you're going to have that
experience in the marketplace I spoke to
this recruitment person and I didn't get
any feedback so it's just maintaining
those standards it's just having the
strength of character to say no I can't
help you even if you think there's a
quick win in the long term that doesn't
create a sustainable recruitment company